Hi everybody! Welcome
to another episode of FP101x.
And what we're going to do today
is we're going to look how to define
functions in Haskell. Now
I think everybody of you that
has been to college in a different town
than where they grew up has had
this experience in one way or
another.
You leave your hometown where you grew
up, you went to
elementary school, you went to highschool,
you go off for college
and then ten years later you come back
and things have changed slightly
but they're also a little bit the same.
And that can be a little bit
disorientating because
in your memory things were
like they were, but in reality they have
changed
slightly.
You will get the same experience when
you look
at Haskell. Haskell looks very familiar
to other programming languages, but it
differs in subtle ways.
And the goal of this lecture is to
walk through some of the syntax of Haskell
function definition and expressions
and compare and contrast these with
how you do these things in other
programming languages.
And once you're aware of these
differences
it will be fairly easy to adopt to them
but
there are some things where Haskell is
definitely a little bit
different than what
most people are used to in Java or
in PHP or whatever your favorite
language is.
So
the first thing is conditional
expressions. Every language has
conditional expressions. And often
there's a difference between conditional
statements,
that are written using if then else,
and conditional expressions,
ternary expressions, that are written
with question mark
colon. Other languages do have if
then else for expressions as well, for
example in Scala
but if you're using C# or
Java, there's the conditional
statements
and then for conditional expressions
there's
different syntax. In Haskell since
there's no statements
when you want to write a conditional
you write
if then else. In this
case we're defining a function that
takes an integer
and returns another integer, and it's
defined..
This is the absolute value. So it
takes
a value and says that if that value is greater
than 0
then you return n else you return -n.
You negate the value. So here you
see that we're using the familiar
if then else as an expression form.
Of course, since it's just an expression
they can be nested as well.
And since conditionals are
expressions
you always have to have a then and an else
part.
So in this case you can define
the sign of a number, so if n is
less than 0
it's -1, if n is zero
then the sign is 0 and else n is
greater than zero, then the sign
is 1. So you always have to
have both
a then and an else branch, just like in ternary
expressions.
Because Haskell people like brevity
they often don't use conditional
expressions, but they use so-called
guarded equations.
And a guarded equation
captures a common pattern where a function
starts with a conditional.
So, if the right hand side of a function
definition immediately has a conditional
it's often nicer to use this form with
guarded equations. So you write your
function definition on your left hand side
and then you write you're conditions
here, so
the absolute value of n is
n when n is greater than or equal to 0
or it's -n otherwise. And otherwise is
just
another alias for True. Now let's
go back to
the definition here, of the absolute value
using a conditional.
And here you see what I said.
This is a function
that is defined immediately using
a conditional.
And Haskell people prefer to write it
like this. And now you see that the right hand
side
is simpler and the cases are
more distinguished. You can easily
reason about this.
If it's greater than 0 or
if it's less than zero. And the other
function, especially when you have nested
conditionals
this becomes even more worthwhile.
So in order to define the sign of a
number: if it's less than zero
-1, if it's equal to zero 0
and otherwise it's one. Here you see
the kind of mathematical heritage of
Haskell
where we like to write things in a very
concise way. And these guarded equations
are something that are very
idiomatic Haskell. So typically you don't
write
if then else, you write
these guarded equations.
Another thing that
is very heavily used in Haskell
and that few contemporary languages
have is pattern matching.
Scala for example has pattern
matching
but there you have to use a case statement
to do the pattern matching.
C# will get pattern matching.
It uses the switch statement.
But in Haskell you can use pattern
matching directly when you define
functions. So for example when we
want to define negation, function from
Bool
to Bool, we can define it with pattern
matching directly. We can say not of
False
equals True and not of True equals
False.
That is a very very concise
definition of negation. Let's look at
another example.
Say that we want to define &&
of two booleans, a function from
Bool to Bool to Bool
and we just write down
the truth table for &&. So this is
exactly how you... if you look
up the definition
of && in any book on digital logic, you
will see the same truth table here.
We can write that down, but if you look at
all of this, you see that it can be
written
even more compactly. Because the only
case
where this thing is true is when
both arguments here are true.
And in all other cases it's false. So you
can take
these four cases here and collapse them
down to these two.
True && True equals True and
otherwise
whatever and whatever equals False.
And this underscore here is used
very very often in Haskell and it means
this is a variable that I don't care about.
It's just used as a placeholder
when doing pattern matching.
If you look at this definition
it will evaluate
both arguments
in order to do this match, because we're
putting a pattern
on both sides of the &&.
Haskell people are very sensitive to
this, because Haskell is a lazy language
and
you want to do as little
evaluation as possible
in order to find
the answer to
this function call. A nicer
definition
according to the Haskell idiom is the
following:
If it's True then
True and something is the same as b
and False and whatever is False.
Let's see if this is true. True
and True equals True. True and
False
equals False. So True and whatever
is there
is whatever was there. And if it's
False on the left hand side, it doesn't
matter what's here on the right hand side.
It's
always False. This is actually
the most
optimal definition of
&& because it only
evaluates the first argument
as necessary.
In Haskell patterns are matched in
order.
They are matched top to bottom left
to right, or left to right
top to bottom, if I'm really precise.
And so the compiler does not try to
rearrange
the patterns necessarily to
make them more optimal, because the order
is important and you can intermix
pattern matching
with guarded equations.
The easiest thing to think about is that
patterns are always matched
left to right, top to bottom.
You cannot repeat variables, for example:
You cannot say b && b equals b
and assume that this is implicitly doing
equality
over b. All the variables
inside a pattern must be unique.
One thing that we have seen: we have
written lists using these square brackets.
And these square brackets really are just
syntactic sugar for
writing the list using explicit
cons and empty list.
When a list
a constant list appears in some place
it will mean this, but inside pattern
matching
we often have to write lists in this form.
So for example when we want to define
the head of a list, we define it using
pattern matching as follows:
We write the list in head
tail form. Let's call it like that.
The head of a list, with head x and
tail
I don't care, is the head. And the tail
of a list, with a head that I don't care
about, and tail xs
is xs. So again
very concise definitions. And just for
fun
let's look at the types. Tail takes
a list
and since the tail of a list
is a list
the type is list
to list. Head takes a list
but the value of the head
is the element type of the list, so
it's a, so this thing goes from list
of a to a. Of course
these are not total functions, because
head and tail
are not defined on the empty list.
When I apply head to the empty list
there's no pattern that matches
and so what you will get is
an error. And the same for tail.
Another way to say that
is that a pattern like this
x:xs only matches
a non-empty list. If you call head
with the empty list
this pattern here
doesn't match, because it's not of the form
x cons anything.
When you see head of empty list, there's no
case that matches
you get an error. The other thing
is that you have to parenthesize
these list
patterns, because application
binds strongest.
This would mean head of x cons
anything, so you have to put
parentheses
in these patterns to make it work.
Alright.
That was our first part of defining
functions in Haskell.
See you after the break.